And now it's the old scout master.
Some scouts were canoeing up in Canada
And one of the scouts was very excited.
He ran back to the campsite
And he told everybody that he just saw a moose.
And the scout master asked him.
He said: well, was it a cow or a bull?
And the scout said no, no, no,
It was a moose.
Hey, this is podcast number 191..
Hey
Well, welcome back to the scout master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag.
Wow, lots in the mailbag this week.
Dan Newsvick got in touch to say
just discovered the podcast tonight.
I love it,
Thank you
Well. thank you, Dan.
Thanks for the kind words.
I'm glad you're enjoying the podcast.
Ed Bruce got in touch to say:
excellent podcast, Clark.
I listened to it on my way to our monthly round table.
Great information.
I'm going to use your 15-minute patrol leader training.
Thank you
Thanks for listening, Ed.
I sure appreciate it.
Ben Moon is a cup master with PAC 19
and an advancement trailer with troop team and crew 19
in Carthage, Missouri
And he wrote in to say:
I have recently learned of your blog
and I've enjoyed it.
I've been sharing your podcast
and email post with some of our newer scouts,
encouraging them to subscribe. also,
Thanks for spreading the word, Ben.
Richard Putnam is a scout leader
with the first Kirkfield scout troop in Winnipeg, Manitoba,
And Richard wrote to say:
first off, I very much appreciate your emails
and informative discussions.
As for the pioneering challenge that you recently posted,
did you guys, did you guys see that
It was on the blog last week?
I suggest to you that MC Escher
must have drawn the diagram
because it looks very similar to his staircase images.
Richard, how very perceptible of you,
And, I must say, many others who did figure out that,
hey, that's an Escher-esque pioneering project.
Richard goes on to say
the diagram as such is physically impossible to build.
Yes, yes, it is.
It would not be possible to actually build that tower.
Keep up the great work.
I'm hoping that that was just a little joke
for those who fail to look wide enough.
Yes, it was, Richard.
Just a little bit of pioneering humor, right?
Bill Kassler is a unit commissioner
in the Bear Paw Council up in Alaska
And he read a post that we had a week or so ago
called Look for Red Lantern Moments.
The Red Lantern is an award
given to the last person to finish the annual.
I Did A Rod dog sled race,
And Bill said this.
first let me tell you how much I enjoy your blog.
I share a lot of what you published in a weekly newsletter
and everyone loves your material, so keep it coming.
I had to smile when you posted about the I Did A Rod.
One of Great Alaska Council's old district executives,
Justin Savitas, ran the I Did A Rod race.
for the last several years
Justin's dogs wear scout neckerchiefs,
The lead dogs are wearing eagle neckerchiefs
and they work their way down to tiger cub neckerchiefs
on the dogs in front of the sled.
I can't even imagine that there would be
mushers out there running the I Did A Rod.
that had something to do with scouting, right,
I mean, it's just a natural.
Thanks for that, Bill. Keep warm up there, okay?
Warren Cofield is a scout master with
Troop 93 in Santa Maria, California,
And in reference to our scout circle
which we had last night- and more about that in a moment-
Warren said: when my son joined scouts,
we didn't even own a backpack.
Now our garage is full of outdoor gear.
When you tell the scouts and his troop,
the more you go, the more you know.
Things don't have to be expensive, just smart.
This last June I was lucky enough to spend
seven nights in the Yosemite High Sierras
with my son. We had a fantastic trip.
One morning at 6 am,
it was 30 degrees outside of our tent
and my son peeked out of his sleeping bag
to say: you know, this is awesome.
And I felt like a dad watching his boy
hit a grand slam in the bottom of the ninth.
I didn't get any better. Well, a cup of coffee
might have helped a little.
There's a lot of great activities in scouting,
but backpacking and the trail is where
a scout can just be a scout,
hopefully with a light pack.
Thanks, Warren, It's a great story.
Burke Huffnagle wrote in to say
I greatly appreciate your site.
Last May my friend told me about it
and I finished listening to all the
archive podcasts in late September.
Thank you for taking the time to share
your wisdom with us. Well, thank you, Burke,
for getting in touch. Thank you, Burke,
for the kind words and for getting in touch.
I really do appreciate it when folks get
in touch and you can email me
at Clark C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom.
Now, as I said, we just did
our October scout circle last night
And as our guest we had Joe
Jacaruso, very experienced backpacker.
Amongst other things. Joe is also
a through hiker of the
2000 plus mile Appalachian trail
And he joined us for an hour
of talking about scouts and backpacking
and the essential skills
that any adult who's going to lead scouts
on a backpacking trip needs to know.
So make sure you check that out.
You can go to scoutscircleorg
to see the presentation
and I'll have it posted to
scoutmastercgcom before the end of the week.
Now our next scout circle
is Sunday November 10th
and this happens between 9 and 10 pm
Eastern Daylight Time
and it happens on Google Plus
and at scoutscircleorg
And it's a live presentation.
It lasts about an hour.
Folks who are watching
are able to ask questions about it
and in November we're going to be talking
about the weeblos to scout transition,
because you know we're getting
to that point in the year where that moves
to the top of the list for a lot of scout troops
and a lot of weeblos stands as well.
So if you have questions or advice
about the weeblos to scout transition,
get in touch with us
and perhaps it'll be part of our next scout circle.
Once again, Sunday November 10th,
9 to 10 pm
Eastern Daylight Time
at scoutscircleorg.
I've been working hard over at the blog
to get things. set up
for the launch of the new book,
which is called The Scouting Journey,
and keep your eyes open. I promise
we're working on it. It's going to be published
in November. I'm going to share
a little bit from the book with you
later on in the podcast
when we do our minute for Scoutmasters.
but before we do that,
in Scoutmastership
in seven minutes or less, we're going to talk about
Quartz of Honor
and that's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
so let's get started, shall we?
Scoutmastership in seven minutes
or less.
So
the final step in advancement
is recognizing a scout
by presenting them
with the achievements that they've earned,
and this is done
at a ceremony called
Quartz of Honor.
In the Guide to Advancement 2013,
it says this: when the Board of Review
has approved his advancement,
the scout deserves recognition
as soon as possible. This should be done
at a ceremony at the next
unit meeting. The certificate for his
new rank may be presented later
during a formal Quartz of Honor.
While we know that we're headed
towards a Quartz of Honor for a formal
recognition of the scout's achievement,
we want to get him the badge
as soon as possible.
Not only people will do that at the next
troop meeting or crew meeting or whatever,
and just with a
quick recognition,
maybe as a part of the announcements and things like that,
just to make sure that the scout
gets the badge right away.
And then the certificate, the little card
that comes with the badge- you can hold on
to that and give it to
them at the Quartz of Honor.
Now some people worry that if they don't
hold on to the badges the scouts aren't
going to attend the next Quartz of Honor, and I
I guess that's a reasonable concern.
but I'd be more concerned that there may be
a couple of things wrong with the way that
we're presenting Quartz of Honor
that could be causing scouts to stay
away from it, if that's a problem.
So what I want to do is give you
kind of several rules of thumb here,
Just running the Quartz of Honor Now, to my way of thinking,
it should be the senior patrol leader
or scouts in leadership
positions should be running that
Quartz of Honor, not the adults.
At our last troop Quartz of Honor,
one of our senior scouts was working on
communications merit badge and he asked
if he could emcee, and the
senior patrol leader thought that that was a great
idea. so he emceed
the Quartz of Honor and I think
that's a great way to
make things happen.
If you're putting on a Quartz of Honor and the scouts are
kind of meh about it,
it might be that if it's the
adults or the troop committee handing out
badges and the scouts are just kind of watching,
they're not going to be all that interested
in attending right. Another rule of thumb
that will help liven up a Quartz of Honor
is the length of time
that it takes. How long is
a Quartz of Honor supposed to be?
Well, our troop has
35 to 40 scouts on average
and we have a table full of
things to present at most Quartz of Honor,
and my rule of thumb is
that we need that Quartz of Honor to last
less than an hour. 30 to 45
minutes is about where you want
to be. If it's less than that,
it's less than that and that's not a problem.
If we have everybody there for two hours
of long,
formal, drawn out presentations,
you know that's an awful
lot to sit through. If we're presenting
an Eagle Rank, which we do as a part
of our regular Quartz of Honor,
it may go just a bit longer,
but brevity is good. and if we're going to ask families
to be there with younger siblings and things
like that. we want to keep that program
moving along. We don't want to skip
anything. We don't want to artificially
shorten it so that we miss
meaningful moments. Pay attention
to how long that Quartz of Honor is taking.
Next, I would suggest that the program
be formal without
being real, theatrically
overblown. You know, simple words spoken
in honesty are almost always
better, at least to my mind, than a lot of
pageantry. Scouts want
some formality and ceremony,
but not at a point where it's so overblown
that it makes them feel
silly or reluctant to participate
in it. So if the program is formal
and meaningful and well done
and it's not way overblown
and it doesn't have all kinds of
crazy elements thrown into it, Scouts
will enjoy it or
at least endure it. right,
What else is happening
at the Quartz of Honor? I know that
most people usually combine the Quartz of Honor
with some announcements
or discussion with families.
Now we have a parent's business
meeting for a few minutes before
each Quartz of Honor And we have
a Quartz of Honor on a quarterly basis.
We talk to parents about the
scheduling of camping trips
or rechartering or
any kind of business that needs to be taken
care of. That part of the program
needs to be quick. It doesn't
need to be a long, drawn out question
and answer period or something like that,
because everybody's going to be there
once the program is concluded
and we can talk about
details and get into things with
individuals after we've presented
the program. Another rule of thumb is
when you schedule a Quartz of Honor.
Now we schedule our Quartz of Honor
in place of a regular
troop meeting. That way
it's on everyone's schedule already.
They already know that
in our case, Monday nights is scout night,
so they don't have to
add another night to the calendar,
and a family with a couple of active children
is likely to have a pretty
involved schedule of meetings
and activities. I think it's important
to make things easy for families
to remember and easy
for them to fit into their busy
schedules. Now, if you apply
some of these ideas, some of these rules of thumb,
you may find that parents and scouts
are more interested in Quartz of Honor
and they make a point out of attending.
There's little chance you're going to get every single scout
and every single family
to any given Quartz of Honor. so do what I do:
Concentrate on the ones that show up
and change things around
so that more will show up if that's what's needed.
Now, if you're putting on a Quartz of Honor
and nobody's showing up
or you feel that the attendance is way down,
the first thing we ought to do
is look at what we're doing
and why we're doing it
and understand that scouts and families
vote with their feet on things like this.
If they aren't showing up,
it's likely that we have something off base
and we need to make adjustments.
So just to run over that advice one more time:
remember that right after a border review
and a scout's been approved
for his next rank
or a merit badge has been filed,
as soon as that's all been reported
and you have the badges in hand,
get them to the scouts.
For a more formal Quartz of Honor,
I suggest an hour is maximum
and less is even better.
that the program needs to be appropriately
formal without being way
dramatically overblown.
that the scouts need to run their own Quartz of Honor.
that if we're going to
combine the Quartz of Honor with a business meeting
for parents or something like that,
we need to keep that part of the program
brief and meaningful.
Busy families with lots on the schedule
usually appreciated if you
have a Quartz of Honor on your standard
meeting night because that's already
on their calendar. Holding regular
Quartz of Honor every quarter
is a good practice
and it keeps everybody in touch with what's going on
and it gives you a chance to recognize
scouts in a timely manner
at that formal Quartz of Honor.
If the attendance at your Quartz of Honor
is a little thin, it may not be
the fault of the audience. it may be
adjustments or fixes that you need
to make to make it worthwhile
and meaningful to attend.
That's right. it's time
for a Scoutmasters Minute.
As I said earlier, my new book, The Scouting Journey,
is going to be published towards the middle of next month.
What it is is it's my attempt
to take about 1600
blog posts
and 191 podcasts
and
and boil it all down into one good, clear,
distinct vision. that is something
that a Scouter could pick up
and hopefully understand something of the width
and the breadth of what Scouting
is supposed to do for our young people,
and to give them solid ideas about
helping them inform
the work that they do as Scouters.
Let me share with you
something out of the book that I think is important
for all Scouters to understand, and that is
the Scouter as a Guide.
We're talking about giving them a general push
in the right direction, a suggestion
rather than a command,
a question asked rather than an answer
given, and then letting them
find their own way,
and I think that's what sets Scouting apart
from so many other things that children do.
so imagine
you're on a bus tour of some
city- okay- and you're seated
in an air-conditioned
motor coach, listening to a guide
drone on and on, the way the guide
sometimes do, and the bus
is rolling along and the guide is explaining
each landmark that we pass
in detail, so we're not going to miss
anything. in fact,
there's so much explaining
that there's not a whole lot of time left
for us to ask questions. and the guide
is a great guide. they stick to the script.
and we sit behind the
tinted windows of our bus, dutifully turning
our heads to the left and looking over
at that building over there
and to the right, and we see that building over there
and after a while the tour is over.
now contrast that bus tour
with a hike that's
guided by some knowledgeable
outdoorsman. our group takes the lead
and finds the trail. now where the trail
branches, our guide will let
us know which way to go
if we can't figure it out on our own,
that he doesn't mind if we stop now
and then to admire a flower or take
in the view, and he'll happily tell us
about anything we're looking at if we ask.
our outdoorsman is not going to
volunteer a whole lot of information.
he'll drop a hint here and there.
he'll ask questions.
we may miss a couple of things
along the way and we might pass by
interesting things, but we'll probably get more
out of what we discovered
on the hike than the things that the
tour guide told us on the bus.
so, like that
outdoorsman, like the guide,
scouters are more responsive
than directive.
so it's that spirit of the guide
that I think is important for us
to think about as scouters.
every individual scout is different
and every group of scouts has different needs.
now, when we're working with younger scouts,
our style is still going to be the guide.
it's going to be a little more directive
and as they grow older,
hopefully we've laid the basis
for them to guide themselves
and to find their own way
and to discover what scouting is all about.
and pretty soon we've kind of
faded into the background
and our role is the same as
that outdoorsman, that guide
who lets the group take the lead
and find the trail and discover these things
for themselves-
music,
well, thanks so much for listening to this edition,
the 191st edition
of the scout master podcast.
we'd love to hear from you.
if you can touch,
you can read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there,
subscribe to receive updates to the blog by email.
you can get access to the podcast on any mobile device
through stitchercom,
and we're also on iTunes.
you can experience all the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
that's right. you can follow us at
scoutmaster blog on facebook,
tweet scoutmastercg on twitter
and watch us at scoutmastercg on youtube.
and if you're on google plus,
look for scoutmastercg
and we'll get you in our exclusive scoutmastercg circle.
if social media doesn't do it for you,
hey, you can email me. zoom into the late 90s.
it's Clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E
the scoutmaster blog
and scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
no, it's just me
talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scoutleaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
speaking of fun, here's our founder,
Sir Robert Badenpal.
Sir Robert, good luck to you and good camping.
why? thank you, sir,
until next time
you.